où
nous
[Musique]
ils sont les seuls français à des
centaines de kilomètres à la ronde
alors mais le poteau dans l'enclos pour
faire la pesée
du coup on se met derrière le propos et
on crie shot show il nous a fallu des
heures de route pour les trouver au
coeur de la mongolie
bonjour tu vas bien je vais bien merci
leur diplôme d'ingénieur agronome en
poche maxime et lolita ont quitté leur
confort occidental pour le confort plus
rustique des éleveurs mongols une
expérience qu'ils nous ont fait partager
à l'autre bout du monde et deux ans
jamais j'aurais imaginé que je serai ici
avec cette équipe au milieu des steppes
en train d'attraper les moutons par les
pattes pour les peser
dans les steppes mongoles
nous avons aussi suivi alexandre zurcher
organisateurs d'expédition à moto
espace cette nature à perte de vue on
traverse à l'auto
notre enquête
et steven jyles darian l'un de ces
guides il est arrivé il ya six mois en
mongolie un pays grand comme trois fois
la france où la densité de population
est la plus faible du très sérieuse avec
la nature ou bien nulle part il ya deux
habitants au kilomètre carré
des animaux partout on peut que se
sentir bien
[Musique]
oulan bator la capitale entre
gratte-ciel et quartier nomades
nous avons rencontré yannick un breton
des côtes d'armor venu pour la première
fois il ya 20 ans juste après la chute
du communisme
six cent mille habitants qui vivaient
ici maintenant il ya un million trois
cent vingt ans et beaucoup de gens qui
sont venus de la compagnie les immeubles
qui se construisent partout mais je sais
pas si pour satisfaire toute la demande
[Musique]
la mongolie attire les amateurs
d'authenticité et de sensations fortes
ces français nous ont ouvert les portes
de ce grand pays coincé entre la russie
au nord et la chine au sud
parcourir les steppes c'est la vie
quotidienne de lolita et maxime il
travaille pour deux associations
françaises qui aide les nomades à
améliorer leurs techniques agricoles il
leur faut parfois faire dix heures de
route pour les rejoindre c'est ça qui
rend le voyage est encore plus
intéressant est encore plus excitant
c'est le fait que la ralentir
peut-être que là on va crever ya nulle
part et on sait pas encore se détend
resté bloqué dans une rivière enfin il
peut arriver plein de choses voilà des
petits jeunes torturent surprise ce
matin ils ont rendez vous avec un
éleveur qu'ils connaissent bien bonjour
tout le monde va bien
balas et d'allemagne m donc elle va avec
qui on travaille maintenant depuis deux
ans sur le programme génétique avec sa
femme
tuée mis un beau manteau ils sont
habillés pareil
à 26 ans maxime a choisi d'exercer son
métier dans l'un des plus grands pays
d'élevage du monde c'est un mouton du
programme oui oui c'est un mouton du
croisement
pendant ses études maxime a appris à
croiser les races pour améliorer leur
rendement en lait viande ou laine ici
c'est un test grandeur nature pour
rendre ces brebis plus résistantes au
froid des hivers mongol nos animaux du
programme on les a identifiés ils ont
une boucle jaune sur les oreilles et du
coup on peut avoir
ces petits et on prend les les plus
petits
c'est un petit peu compliqué
alors comment on fait pour le maintenir
ou non le mets sur les fesses et on cale
ses jambes de chaque côté de l'animal
et ça marche
échec et ils sont lourds
c'est possible c'est bon signe
et plus de 100 partis 60 36 ans ça c'est
la réussite du programme et et c'est que
la première année donc donc voilà donc
on va continuer comme ça avec daniel
vous voyez celui ci c'est un agneau qui
n'a pas été croisés il est plus chétifs
que celui que tient maxime sakho est
plus petit hélas beaucoup moins de
l'aisne ils ont dit qu'is l'autre
différence
grâce au croisement des agneaux nous
allons pouvoir augmenter nos revenus
fixes je suis très reconnaissant à
maxime et lolita ils nous ont beaucoup
aidés
celle adoptée il allait lever drame au
rachat elle dit qu'elle va l'emmener
chez elle de voir que les gens sont
contents du résultat bah moi ça nous
savons juste heureuse en fait on essaie
de travailler ensemble et d'améliorer un
peu bas la vie de tous les jours et
ce qui est touchant et kylie qui est
motivant en fait maxime et lolita ont
adopté le mode de vie ancestral des
éleveurs ont goal
bichonne
quand ils ne sont pas en mission ils
vivent ici accès de serre lègue
une petite ville de 18000 habitants à
huit heures de route d'oulan bator
il partage cette petite maison dans un
quartier populaire
à mon choix c'est maxime et hop une
bonne société dont les petits outils
le confort est plutôt rudimentaire
c'est notre robinet douche on s'en sort
pour tous ces parfaits
et après ça tout le monde le sautier là
aussi on oublie de sortir le soda après
ça
ça dégouline partout vous vue à la
française mobile à la mongole alors
on a choisi vivre à la nouvelle embellie
n'est encore de l'africom ainsi en
afrique aux manettes et c'est non on va
chercher le cuir la nôtre poil pour nous
chauffer il n'y a pas d'eau courante
on a comme l'électricité mais si on
regarde et on est relié aux poteaux
électriques de la rue donc c'est enfin
ces travaux on adore ça parce que ça
c'est vrai top après c'est vrai que
l'univers sont pas forcément toujours
évident parce que dans un appartement on
t'aura toujours chaud ici si tu te lèves
pas quatre heures dans la nuit pour
faire le feu le lendemain matin il fait
moins 20 dans la baraque il ya un peu
des inconvénients l'hiver un peu fidal
de et tout ça ça passe
l'hiver il peut faire jusqu'à moins 35
degrés
où il fait trop beau la
bad et y en a un qui avait avoir un
petit coup de mou bello tu vas être
l'air un peu pour l'heure booster je
pense qu on se motive aussi pas mal pour
dans le boulot et puis même dans la vie
de tous les jours alors que tu vas
chercher l'eau au puits pareil tout seul
c'est pas très compliqué c'est comme ça
que ça peut paraître un peu dingue de
français qui habitent ici au milieu de
nulle part en angola pour la défense
c'est un peu la remarque aussi mais là
quand on se lève et connaissait de vue
c'est quand même chouette et on est seul
sur terre
c'est le début d'une journée de bureau
comme les autres pour maxime et lolita
auprès des tribus nomades
la vie a comme un petit peu de liberté
[Musique]
à 500 km de là c'est une autre mongolie
fut oulan-bator une des villes les plus
polluées du monde
sur la place centrale trône la statue de
gengis khan le fondateur au 12e siècle
de l' empire mongol l'un des plus
puissants et des plus grand de toute
l'histoire
60% des mongols vivre à oulan bator
beaucoup sont d'anciens nomades qui
habite à la périphérie du centre-ville
c'est dans ce quartier populaire que vit
stephenville darian
il partage ce terrain avec une famille
mongole voici sa maison c'est une yourte
donc c'est une habitation traditionnelle
mongole avec le poêle à bois parce que
les hivers sont assez rude et les nuits
sont fraîches steven est lui même un peu
nomade il passe la plupart de son temps
sur la route et s'apprête à partir dans
quelques heures ça c'est un kit de
premiers secours on a un téléphone
satellite en cas d'urgence des fois on
est 200 km du premier hôpital psy a une
vraiment une urgence oui on peut faire
venir on peut faire dire des écouteurs
et vous ressentez koala avant de quitter
votre
les steppes de l'impatience c'est
toujours les dernières heures les plus
longues on va dire je suis surtout
curieux de découvrir les gens avec qui
je vais voyager parce que au final c'est
eux qui font le voyage c'est c'est pour
ça que c'est pour ça que je respecte et
c'est pour ça que j'adore c'est ma
passion aussi
en mongolie la saison touristique ne
dure que trois mois le reste de l'année
les températures sont trop basses
alexandre zurcher propose des
expéditions sur des motos anciennes
c'est le dernier voyage de la saison et
il fait déjà froid en paires de
chaussettes un jean je suis en passe de
mode pour 5e 10 charte
henry et eric deux amis de longue date
arrive d'auvergne cette traversée de la
mongolie il on rêvait depuis longtemps
oui jour de chevaucher pour 3500 euros
tout compris
bien équipé
eric vous vous attendez à quoi là pour
ce voyage est bas des grands espaces de
l'aventuré de la neige
passionné de moto eric embarqué henry
dans ce périple quand tu en rêves parce
que si c'est comme pour la combi puis
ils vont découvrir la mongolie sur ces
engins importés d'inde
la royal enfield une moto mythique
ancien véhicule de l'armée britannique
elle n'a quasiment pas changé depuis les
années 30 déjà c'est de la vieille
mécanique donc c'est une moto qui a
vraiment du charme qui nous permet
d'aller au contact des locaux on n'a pas
le sentiment d'arriver comme des
cosmonautes d'être un peu déconnecté par
rapport à l'environnement qu'on traverse
par ailleurs voilà il roule vraiment un
rythme tranquille donc c'est très
agréable
c'est parti pour une aventure de 1000 km
ils vont rouler à côté des chevaux
traversée des kilomètres de step aux
paysages à couper le souffle
[Musique]
lagence d'alexandre organise des voyages
en inde au népal et au bouton c'est sa
première saison en mongolie c'est mon
premier repérage j'ai été vraiment
séduit par les grands espaces cette
nature à perte de vue cette question de
verre qui est quand même assez
saisissant on le traverse sa moto et je
pense que le voyageur français
aujourd'hui quand il va aussi loin qu en
mongolie il cherche ce type de dpi ce
type de contact et la mongolie propose
vraiment ça à 100 pour ça
on est scotché par la grandeur et la
beauté des paysages scotché c'est le mot
qu'on se croirait sur une autre planète
pratiquement ya aucune autre trace
d'avancées technologiques ou quoi que ce
soit c'est la nature à plein voilà
après quatre heures de piste
enfin un village
pourquoi ça ne marche pas
sainte anne et motos ou tigre est
vraiment ça
est-ce qu'il a besoin d' aide
il demande si on peut t'aider oui venez
m'aider s'il vous plaît nous revient
avec
pouces lax bref ça
et a primé entre toi
et qu'on roule au milieu de nulle part
bonsoir et toujours pour leur donner un
petit coup de main
on ne laisse pas au milieu de la fête je
crois qu'à réparer ça oui c'est moi
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
heureusement que je vous ai rencontrés
vous êtes très gentil
ce genre de moments vous organiser ses
voyages bah oui c'est clair alors
prévenu sein du parti du voyage congrès
sur la queue pour ce type de moment mais
évidemment quand il a le contact de la
population et finalement la meilleure
manière de vraiment rencontrer les gens
c'est dans les moments qui sont un peu
imprévues qui se parent encadré dans des
parcours touristiques traditionnels et
balisés
c'est ça l'esprit nomade je pense dans
l'esprit nomade ya cette entraide
revient peut-être leur rôle c'est de
bien voir
ghazi doucement
merci vous m'avez bien aidé avec un
doigt
si certains découvrent le pays pour la
première fois d'autres français cite ici
depuis bien plus longtemps yannick est
binaire c'est installa oulan-bator il ya
onze ans et en bon breton il a ouvert la
première crêperie du pays
à son arrivée yannick était directeur
commercial pour une grande entreprise
et la prochaine fois que vague aux
secousses je suis là y aura une surprise
une grande surprise
et puis à 60 ans il se lance dans la
restauration
on a fait une galette andouille
avec
confit d'oignon est
très très bonne en cuisine sont équipés
mongol une française est venue les
former longtemps les spécialistes un
fait ça bien
aujourd'hui ils sont devenus les rois de
la crêpe donc vous voyez ne résiste pas
donc c'est tout nouveau pour tout
nouveau jeu des bretons je me suis dit
on n'a pas ici c'est l'opportunité et
donc j'ai dire en train de craquer plus
restaurant parce que d'aucune critique
je ne savais pas si ça allait marcher
seul et les deux marche parfaitement
donc c'est super personnes
yannick veut faire connaître le bon goût
français
à la nouvelle classe aisée de son pays
d'adoption
c'est surtout l'ambiance conviviale qui
plaît
j'aime bien cet endroit parce qu'il n'ya
ni qu'ici
il distrait les clients il est très
amical
mais grâce à lui on dit du bien et en
plus il nous fait boire du gros calvados
la première fois qu'il est venu à
oulan-bator yannick était l'un des seuls
étrangers
le pays s'ouvre est tout juste après
l'effondrement du bloc soviétique
et en attend il ya derrière ce jeu pour
ces mêmes pas certains magasins qui
étaient vais pas danser n'y avait rien
on ouvrait une porte on se disait tiriac
envoyer une boîte de conserve et on
savait que c'était une épicerie quand
c'est marrant donc depuis maintenant
c'est devenu zui l'européenne quoi pour
certains la mongolie est aujourd'hui
devenu le nouvel eldorado
le pays connaît un boom économique sans
précédent grâce à ses immenses richesses
minières le niveau de vie d'une partie
de la population a explosé et près de
150 français s'ils se réinstaller
c'est dans ce marché fréquenté par des
mongols aisés et des expatriés que
yannick à ses habitudes
vous avez votre cuti et oui tu laisses
des courses voilà donc ça c'est une dame
qui fournit pas mal de choses méconnues
mais voilà si on trouve pas encore
d'andouille de guéméné ou de farine de
blé noir les produits importés ont
envahi les étals
yannick se souvient d'une époque pas si
lointaine ouvrir un restaurant français
était impensable 3 kg d'orange
48 multi-week
juste avant j'arrivais encore des
tickets d'approvisionnement là pour les
gens et j'ai eu un grand changement
entre 80 90 et 95
le jour et la nuit
il ya un gros potentiel pour tous ceux
qui ont des idées de nouvelles idées
dans tous les domaines et c'est pas fini
je pense non je pense que le genre de
petit qatar là haut
de petits singapour un truc comme ça
la nuit c'est toulouse bat or qui brille
s'amuse dans les grands hôtels
yannick est invité dans une soirée chic
il est membre du rotary club
j'ai l'astra chanson du rotary
[Musique]
officiellement le membres se réunissent
pour faire des donations à des oeuvres
caritatives
mais c'est surtout un cercle de notables
on y vient pour renforcer son réseau
c'est vraiment un endroit où on
rencontre plein de gens les gens de
qualité en cours
la demi-lieue les domaines des
politiques et privés des patrons de
l'hôtel ici qui fait de l'apport exploit
aussi ya peu tout
[Applaudissements]
yannick le breton a réussi à se faire
une place dans ce milieu très fermé
vous savez les knicks à ce genre de
personne qui est connecté avec tout le
monde ce que tu connais yannick oui bien
sûr
[Musique]
et s'il ne passe pas inaperçu c'est
peut-être grâce à son sens du rythme
[Musique]
oh
j'ai des fous
non
[Musique]
ce soir la bonne société du lan bator se
couchera tard
[Musique]
à 500 km de là au niveau d'août
maxime et lolita prépare une soirée d'un
style très différentes avec eux nous
allons découvrir le passe temps favori
des mongols
oui
ce soir les deux jeunes ingénieurs
agronomes maxime et lolita sorte avec
leurs collègues de bureau tu connais des
chansons
allez vas-y champ en eaux douces et à
toi
il habite depuis deux ans dans cette
petite ville loin de la capitale ils
vivent à la mongole et partagent la même
passion pour le karaoké
là tu peux pas mieux là c'est la bonne
soirée
[Musique]
un karaoké en cyrillique succès garanti
marie jo
[Musique]
tu veux que la petite chanson papa
koné les messages et la chanson mandard
notre chauffeur écoute en boucle de
trois citernes ou le nez parker photo
dppi deux heures tous les jours
[Musique]
mais
nous chante bien distance assez bien je
viens ali aucun cas vécus crois pas
parce qu'ils sont rigolos
[Musique]
soirée les petits concerts en france
alors oui parce que même
[Musique]
la chance d'être
faire la campagne de pouvoir faire la
soirée chez des amis c'est sûr que la
spa n'a pas d'enfants dans les
les concerts des hommes
[Musique]
deux jours après leur départ le groupe
de motards fait escale pour la nuit chez
une famille de nomades
en mongolie tradition oblige on
accueille spontanément les visiteurs
dans la yourte
et ou faites comme chez vous comme toi
généralement réseau
la yourte est un espace fortement ils
s'organisent et
steven a donc ce code de conduite
tellement nos sources le départ
les affaires a pas commettre s'est passé
entre les poteaux sans trop en fait de
la nuance jeter des choses en feu
montrer la plante des pieds
et devant le feu
refuser le lait par exemple quand vous
offre mes ailes et les nomades de toute
façon en savent qu'on est étranger
est ce que tu te le demander comment ça
se passe l'hiver ici parce qu'il fait
jusqu'à moins 50 degrés l'hiver gimp et
ils veulent savoir comment vous vivez
on apprend à vivre avec ce climat
extrême de notre enfance
et ce serait dur car il neige vraiment
tout le temps
quand il neige beaucoup notre bétail a
du mal à trouver de quoi manger
[Musique]
etc ou trois pièces
sont ses dents vous aimez les mots oui
on est le pays où les gens qu'on aime
tout temps beaucoup de l'iphone
les touristes viennent chercher en
mongolie la simplicité de cette ville
rurale
à six années dans l'est beaucoup plus
cool tu mérite un débat là elle va les
taper tout le monde calme toi toi jour
et le chef de famille
il s'appelle volts c'est important pour
nous à partir du moment où voyage en
mongolie de faire vraiment découvrir
aussi le mode de vie nomade traditionnel
donc c'est à ces sujets là c'est génial
de voir que des nomades comme nous
accueillent aussi simplement on va
profiter un petit peu aussi la vie
rurale ont fait comme vous le voyez on
nourrit les chèvres on va peut-être
assister avec eric et henry à la traite
dgac voilà qui on va profiter de ces
endroits qui est absolument magnifique
ça vous dit pas qu'on essaie de lui un
coup de main les gars quand les chevaux
arrivent tout ce qu'on peut mettre en
cercle autour et qu'on lève les bras
pour les arts étaient
rassemblés uniquement pour la traite et
la capture les chevaux mongols vivent
tant aux hordes à moitié sauvage
vous avez déjà vu cette méthode pour
attraper les chevaux oui oui aussi des
bases un film avec john wayne mais à
part ça d'andorre c'est la première fois
que je vois ça
ce matin les motards change de monture
la mongolie est aussi le pays des
randonnées à cheval
vous inquiétez pas les canassons ceux
des royal enfield ça roule tranquille
c'est un petit peu plus haut que la moto
certes on est très bien sur la selle
pour l'instant on va tâcher d'y rester
les voilà partis pour une chevauchée en
direction d'un des plus beaux sites
naturels de mongolie
[Musique]
yannick le citadin aime aussi se
ressourcer dans cette mongolie des
steppes presque tous les week-ends il
vient dans cette vallée elle lui
appartient on met deux en fait à voir
toute cette valise à mongole et moi vous
veillez sur ce qu étaient protégés de
rabah oui sinon il ya trop de monde
c'est pas marrant moi j'aime pas on
comptait peut-être faire une petite
station de ski pour paul hiver avec un
truc pour les enfants on sait pas c'est
un projet mais en fait on fera peut-être
ça sympa
riga rose et rose et yannick à rénover
ce chalet abandonné
vous savez rebonds j'ai faim
c'est comme obélix
comme obélix 1/2 car de muttur
quel menu de ce midi ça bon je recueille
rasées on est combien et 7,8 mois ça va
dit est ce que tu peux aller me chercher
de l'eau avant le repas une petite
partie de pétanque
[Musique]
yannick a initié son groupe d'amis
il y indique apprend à jouer à tous les
gens qu'il invite ici c'est un sport
qu'on ne connaît pas en mongolie mais
quand on apprend on adore
c'est une compétition on devient accro
yannick joue très bien il mène 9 à 0
mais je pense que j'ai toujours une
chance de gagner
tu peux faire des effets tu vois
maintenant essayer de la placer juste à
côté de la mienne
yannick a même lancé le premier club de
pétanque de mongolie il ne compte
aujourd'hui qu'une dizaine de membres
tous très motivés
elle se débrouille bien je dois me
concentrer
alors on arrive dans des endroits comme
ça voilà un petit chalet sympa comment
comment comme dans les alpes et ton
nom c'est ça la vie
pour le groupe de motards c'est bientôt
la fin du voyage
c'est pour avoir des paysages comme ça
il faut faire des fours
voilà les chutes de leurs c'est sa chute
de l'heure
aucun touriste aux alentours la mongolie
c'est aussi ça se retrouver seul dans
des lieux exceptionnels
une beauté naturelle encore méconnu mais
cela pourrait bientôt changer le pays
attire aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
voyageurs
il faut surtout que sa garde son
authenticité il n'y a pas beaucoup de
gens qui viennent visiter en fait la
mongolie et c'est plutôt pas mal les
nomades qu'on croit sur la route est
vraiment des instants intacte j'aimerais
que sprint change pas qu'ils restent
aussi nature est intacte que je vais
trouver cette année
[Musique]
là qu'est ce qu'il ya je veux conduire
allez on y va
il arrive à s'amuser avec eux rien tu
vas il a une plume y rigole il a un
bâton il rigole et ça c'est vraiment
beau quoi te dire qu'avec avec rien et
j'arrive à passer une belle enfance
là bas j'ai un caillou dans ma poche
donne faim
mais donne neuf unités de la bouse mois
le contrat de lolita se termine elle
retourne en france dans quelques mois
j'ai un peu la larme à l'oeil parce que
en tout cas une grande brèche dans le
coeur parce que ces voix là c'est des
gens maintenant qu'ils sont un peu à
notre famille un peu nos amis et ouais
pas que j'ai pour ce sera parce que ça
me met main peut
aller bien le dit ah on va dans la
yourte
c'est une des dernières fois qu'ils se
retrouvent tous ensemble
un moment célébré autour d'une vodka
traditionnelle mongole
lait de vache fermentée et 10 tiller
roussat pitch
servez lui avait
il habite ici depuis deux ans et ils
sont presque devenus mongol comme nous
maxime et lolita ont traversé deux
hivers rigoureux ils ont partagé la vie
difficile des éleveurs ils vivent comme
nous et ils ont réussi à s'adapter ici
les nomades ont fait plus couvrir leurs
portes à maxime et lolita ils leur ont
transmis cet esprit des steppes une ode
à la vie simple ils repartiront avec au
fond d'eux un peu de cette âme nomades
[Musique]